in August 2017 Denver Public Schools
unveiled a new school lunch policy in a
push to end blunt shaming there are
students who are eligible for the
federal free reduced lunch program set
them aside they're not the ones we're
talking about there are students who are
not eligible for federal free reduced
lunch because our families can afford to
pay for lunch with Denver said to these
families is that their children would
get lunch at school if they paid for it
and they would get lunch if they did not
a year later the check came to get from
unpaid lunches in the 2017-18 school
year through more than 25 fold to more
than three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars or about nine hundred unpaid
lunches a day now no one wants to see
children go hungry because of their
family's financial circumstances but
neither do we want to shift ours from
academics to the lunch line due to
feel-good schemes that go south the
lesson even the most well-meaning of
uric retic policies can have unintended
consequences eroding the trust essential
to healthy schools and compassionate
communities is it surprising to you that
so many people seem to take advantage of
Denver's program let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI